all right here we go
[Music]
my name is Daryl Smith my name is
Preston Smith
I'm a scientific glassblower I'm the
senior scientific glass blower at Yale
University housed in the chemistry
Department
they opened the shop in 1924
it's very critical for research to have
somebody on site
there's a vast variety of scientific
glassware that researchers use they're
doing unique research so sometimes it
takes a new glassware some of it's
standard catalog items some of its
modifications of a standard item and
sometimes it's a very unique design
I had this novelty item called bubble
machine where the liquid goes through
the air return captures some of the
liquid and it goes up through a small
tube so I Incorporated that into a line
decanter
you have to get the nozzles done from
just right or the flow won't continue it
won't pull the liquid back up through
and around so you constantly have to
test it and see and then you have to go
back and adjust it
go
this particular project I've made a
couple of different versions to see
which one would work best it's not
something I've seen before so it's a
little bit of trial and error and you
expect that going in so you try
something it's like well I should have
made that first so just do it again this
should be spun from this side every year
being able to physically hold the thing
and see it and look at the sketching and
look at the piece you made and it
matches and it looks like what was
envisioned it's a really cool process to
see that and actually be like okay I did
it right
there are less and less opportunities
for young people to learn this craft and
so it's really a thrill to pass it on to
my son
it's very rewarding to work with my
father he's taught me so much and it's
cool to be able to take what he's taught
me and continue to evolve it and then
Carry On The Legacy in a way
working here with the researchers and
working with people that requests gifts
you're real close to the end user and
you get some immediate feedback
when I finished it and I know that it
works well that's going to be very
satisfying
[Music]